-Our next guest was an NFL
quarterback for 17 seasons
and is now an analyst
for Prime Video's
"Thursday Night Football,"
which premieres
next Thursday, September 15th.
Please welcome to the show
Ryan Fitzpatrick, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright.
-Thank you for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-So, 17 seasons in the league.
And I'm just wondering
over the course of that time,
did you ever
picture broadcasting
being the next step?
Did you consider coaching?
Or did you just think
you were going to play forever?
Because very few people
do 17 years.
-I thought I could play forever.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Had a hip injury last year,
so age started catching up
with me a little bit,
but I think those are
the two natural avenues --
coaching and broadcasting.
Just because it's something
I've essentially dedicated
my whole life to doing.
But coaching is very hard.
A lot of hours.
My kids would be, you know,
not real happy with Dad,
so the broadcasting thing
I think is going to be fun.
I think I've got a lot of
experiences I can share.
And Amazon, with Prime Video
and this new "Thursday Night
Football" package
seemed like
the right fit for me.
-That's also a very important
thing to note.
You actually had
a broadcasting job,
a football broadcasting job,
and you don't work weekends,
which is, for your children,
very kind.
-Which is huge.
-Yeah.
-So I can still be soccer dad.
I can still watch
all of the stuff
that goes on
Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
It's going to be great.
-And we should know that
you're not just a one-kid dad.
-We've got seven.
We've got seven little ones.
-You've got seven kids.
-Yeah, which you have three?
-I have three,
and I'm walking around
being like,
"I'm a real big shot," but, no.
-I will tell you,
I also feel like I'm a big shot,
but my wife left out of town
for about a week.
-Wow!
-So I had all seven of them.
-And is it 3 to 15?
Is that the ages?
-3 to 15.
All the odd years in between.
And I just had to
get out of the way.
They are well-trained.
They asked me to pour milk,
like, in the cereal bowl.
That was, like, Dad's role
for the week basically.
And then one of
my four daughters
asked me to braid her hair.
So I've got the double braid
where you start the braid,
and the hair gets all weird,
so you put the tie in
and then you braid more.
I call it the double braid,
and it's what they love.
-Okay. Great.
What is the --
Just for the logistics
of seven children,
what is the transportation
situation?
-So, it's the only time
we ever had to think about,
are we having another kid?
Because when you go
from six to seven,
you go from minivan
to something else.
So we no longer fit
in a minivan.
We got a big old
12-passenger van,
which is great
when all the kids are in it.
And then when I'm driving it
by myself,
people are like, "Eh.
I don't know about that guy."
-Yeah, I will say, like,
that beard
and an empty passenger van?
-[ Laughs ] It's not great.
-It's not great.
-Not great.
I often have lots of candy, too.
-Oh, yeah.
Well, of course, seven kids.
You're gonna have candy, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Do you -- You played for --
How many different teams
did you play for
over your 17 years?
-Nine.
And does that mean
that you have fan bases
everywhere that consider you
one of theirs?
Are you often approached?
-Yeah, I do.
I would say Buffalo,
the Jets, Miami --
those are probably the three --
Tampa. Those are the four that
if I'm getting approached
in an airport, like,
it's probably one of those four.
It's probably
not St. Louis Rams
and Tennessee and Cincinnati
and those teams.
But, yeah, it's always
interesting, like,
"Okay, what are they
going to come up
and say to me
when they approach me?"
-How about New York?
How do you get treated here?
-You know, 2015 season,
if they remember you
from that season,
they loved me, most of it.
2016, not so much.
So it's like
a 50/50 proposition.
-This is from today.
You got recognized.
We were having a slice of pizza.
[ Laughter ]
-And this is --
I mean, that shows --
When you got
a demographic of fan
who's not using a phone.
-Yeah.
So I think he may --
We were talking about streaming
football on Thursday nights.
I don't know that
he's going to be set up
for the first week to do it.
But we're going to get him
his Prime membership.
-You mentioned Buffalo.
Buffalo had an incredible
first week of playoff football
last year
against the Patriots,
which is obviously a team,
you know --
Everybody in the AFC East
has had trouble
with the Patriots
over the years.
Huge win. You went to the game.
First of all, very impressed.
You did not do
the luxury-box path.
You went and sat with the fans.
How many of your kids
did you bring with you?
-My two oldest.
At the time,
my boys were 14 and 12.
-And it was negative-10 degrees.
-Yeah.
-Here's the photo of you
and I think your oldest.
Now, how did it come about
that you guys decided
to go shirtless?
-The whole way walking through
the parking lot into the gates,
well, they learned
some new words.
We had a guy
with a Mac Jones Jersey
walking by us, and so plenty
of expletives being thrown.
But my boys the whole time
were like,
"Dad. Shirts off. Shirts off."
So it was just -- I felt like
I was in college again,
getting peer-pressured
to, like, go drinking
or something, you know?
And so the Bills score
seven touchdowns in a row,
which, like, has never happened.
And I thought,
"This is the moment, boys."
And so we ripped them off and --
-I would imagine
the fans in the area
were pretty proud of you
as a former Bill.
-Well, and we had --
Then other people started
taking their shirts off,
as well.
-So the peer pressure
goes both ways.
-Yeah, it does, it does.
-This is one of my favorites.
I remember this photo
from a press conference.
DeSean Jackson was a
wide receiver with you in Tampa.
And can you explain how
you ended up in his clothes?
-So D-Jack walks through
the locker room,
and what he's wearing,
I just --
I felt like it was something
I could never get away with.
Anything he wears looks cool.
-Yeah.
-And I'm always
complimenting him.
And so he walks through
with this get-up and chains.
I'm like, "D-Jack,
I could never wear that.
People would just laugh me
off the stage, essentially."
And he said, "Well, if we
win today, you're wearing it."
And so, we win the game, press
conference comes up, and...
-And I got to be honest.
You pull it off.
-It's not bad, right?
-It's not bad.
-But he's --
It's really not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
-He's 60 pounds lighter than me,
so it was a little snug.
-Yeah, it's a little snug,
but this is really
the highest compliment.
I mean, I can tell you
you pulled it off,
but then your son decided
to wear it for Halloween.
-Yes.
-So he really pulls it off.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-With the pencilled-in
chest hair there, too.
With the pencilled-in
chest hair.
For me, that's the highest
compliment as a father --
your son dressing up like you
for Halloween.
I felt like nowhere to go
but down now as a father.
-Also, it should be noted
Richard Sherman, Al Michaels --
You're really with one of the
all-time greats in the booth.
-So, Al Michaels
and Kirk Herbstreit,
which they're both --
The voices are iconic.
When Al's just telling
a conversation
and he's speaking,
he's ordering a steak for lunch,
you're just mesmerized
by his voice.
Yeah, and then Richard Sherman
is going to be great.
He's freshly off the field,
as well.
And he's a defensive guy,
so I think we're going to have
a lot of battles in terms
of what we like going on
in the game and what we don't.
That's going to be
real interesting.
And then the hall-of-famer
Tony Gonzalez
and Charissa Thompson.
-Well, it's a great group.
And it was really exciting
and cool
to watch you for 17 years
on the field,
and I'm really excited for
this next chapter, as well.
Thanks for making time
for us, man.
Ryan Fitzpatrick, everybody.
"Thursday Night Football"
premieres Thursday,
September 15th, on Prime Video.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."